but this is what women do all right
women will divorce your ass and get mad
when you move on because they think
you're just going to be under their
spell for a lifetime and when you say
okay see you lady and you get a younger
hotter tighter model like he did
they get a bit mad now I am actually
happy for him because I heard he was
dating Kim Kardashian now it seems like
he is not this is all speculation guys
just so you know but apparently he has a
new romance with Arena shank if I said
her name wrong I'm sorry this is who I
am a beautiful younger woman you know
and they always say the second wife is
an upgrade I don't know what to tell you
guys